hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna gonna fix some some things that
broke on this this main project project
five that we've been working on so a lot
of things broke whenever I updated to
the latest version of material UI so
it's version 1.2 point O so at first I
had thought about just holding off on
updating because we were so close to
launch and then we ended up not
launching whenever I wanted to
so I based on some advice from I believe
it was Christian that had suggested not
to get too far behind which i think is
good advice I decided to go ahead with
the update I figure it's better to be on
a stable release version before we go
live anyway and since we have a little
bit more time now before we launch it
may as well get it over with now so
that's what we're gonna be working on
I'm gonna say what's up to everybody in
the live chat here before we get started
we may only end up doing like one
Pomodoro session I'm gonna see we'll see
how it goes
Danny ki noticed the hacks over first
t-shirt so this is the if you
participate in October fest which is
it's an event where I believe you have
to make three contributions to open
source projects so if you make three
contributions in the month of October
then you get this shirt and some
stickers yeah I think we got yeah we
definitely got a sticker so that was fun
so if you didn't get to do
this past year definitely look out for
that in in October I assume it's gonna
happen again it's okay
Siberian says what's the too long didn't
watch of the new updates well the one
new component they have but I'm really
excited about is a swipeable drawer so
that when you're on your phone you can
swipe the drawer like in and out which
which I've wanted for a long time for
this project so that's really cool and I
do want to transition over to that
drawer but not until after we fix all
the things that are broken right now but
basically the name of the package I'll
go through in a minute when I start my
Pomodoro session first I'll go through
some of the biggest changes that I've
already dealt with today and then we'll
just continue on with with what I left
off but that should give you an idea of
the new updates as well hi Jilly says I
was just fixing my own material I
project when I got the notification for
this video great timing Oh awesome I'm
glad well maybe maybe it'll help you out
a bit
alright sobre hard says say my name so
there you are
let's see the beginning sis I don't know
programming that's cool uh you're
welcome to watch and ask questions
Briard also asks are you in Germany no
I'm not in Germany I'm in the United
States okay all right let's uh let's get
started I'm gonna start my Pomodoro
timer so for about twenty-five minutes
I'm gonna you know maybe I'm not gonna
look at the live chat too much
then after that 25 minutes I'll come
back and answer as many questions as I
can in the chat let me switch over okay
I'll make this a bit bigger so y'all can
see the font and then I'll start to go
over what we've done I just noticed Bray
Bray Hart says never watch the free code
camp livestream so show me what you got
yeah so if you've never watched one
before here's the deal with my live
streams I mess up a lot live and then I
try to fix it so if that's if that is
the heart of this live stream you will
definitely find it today because I have
messed up a very important part of my
project mainly what I'm working on right
now is that side drawer that main menu
that's on every single page doesn't work
it will I click it the state actually
changes and reacts so the state changes
from true to false for whether or not
it's open that works but there's two
things that seem to have changed with
the new version one on the the container
itself for that side drawer there's a
some CSS added that makes such a -
visibility:hidden and then on the body
of the page it sets it to
overflow:hidden those things don't go
away so when I click to open the
visibility:hidden doesn't change so it
stays hidden and when I click to close
the overflow for the body stays hidden
as well so you can't scroll so I don't
know why those issues are affecting it
I've been through my markup to try to
see and it's exactly the same as what's
in the demos on the site so it's it's a
little frustrating but first let me show
you some of what
I've already fixed and what's already
been changed Joey asked what version I
was upgrading from I was at beta 38
so going from beta 38 we're skipping
quite a few versions here to get up to
the latest one okay so you can see here
our dependencies now say you know at
material UI core at material UI icons so
before we didn't have this at symbol
right we didn't have the core there
either so the name of the package
changed so if you're gonna upgrade
you're gonna want to remove the previous
packages and then add these packages as
they're named here okay so that's a huge
difference you know completely different
packages you can't just update the
existing ones
all right they'd there is this code mod
package that came through that's
supposed to help update everything but I
couldn't get it to work
I follow the instructions I don't know
what the problem is you can see some of
the remnants of me attempting this in
the terminal here so what I did was I
manually went through because a lot of
since the package changed the way we
import things change as well so we
import things from at material UI / core
so I went through and just did a fine in
replace for all those and then also the
icons have changed as well so it's at
material UI icons so I went through a
control fine replaced all those not only
that but there were a lot of times where
you could lump together a bunch of
things so like I could do list list item
and list icon all together in one import
right I just used brackets and bring it
all in I'd import it all from list we
can't do that any
or now you have to import them
separately so you import list item from
list item list item icon from the side
of my clone right and that happened in
quite a few places so that script was
supposed to help so that I wouldn't have
to do that unfortunately I couldn't get
it to work so what I did was with the
help of the errors i was getting in my
terminal i went through and found the
places where i had to replace those
things and I checked the material ID
documentation Oh for the right for the
right way to do that so those changes
were kind of boring anyway so i'm i
think it's it's okay we didn't do it on
the stream because it was just a lot of
copy and pasting reading error messages
and then going to the right file so if
you do want to do it again
i recommend trying to get that script to
work if you can't though the best thing
is just trace where it's telling you
it'll tell you the file where is
happening in the line you scroll down
you figure out what component was on
that line and then you scroll up and
change based on the documentation you
you change the import and that that
pretty much solved all those errors so
not getting these errors anymore but
still not everything's working so let's
let's look around some more
let's let's try to fix this let me pull
over on this screen I don't think I need
these we'll get rid of that save some
say some RAM but I'm gonna pull over on
the screen the drawer just to show you
what's going on so there was one issue
as well on these pages but that's was
unrelated to the update so I I did fix
that so I want to go to oops
see it's the one that weird
overflow:hidden thing it's also annoying
this so this is not so
supposed to be an oval behind here so
there there are some weird things
happening also there was a change with
the way the grid works the grid items
automatically had some spacing between
them but now that's all set to zero so
you have to manually put in spacing so
we'll have to go in here and put in
spacing between these buttons now the
site is not normally really slow like
this it's just because I'm running the
strain
all right so you can see we click that
and it opens here's why it opens in the
drawer I have manually a manually added
visibility:visible in line so it
overrides what was happening before all
right I'd rather not manually override
what's supposed to be happening but if
that's how I have to fix this that's
that's how I'll fix it what I'm tempted
to do since I'm trying to figure out
what's happening anyway is implement
that that drawer
the swipeable drawer implement that now
and see if implementing that will solve
any of our issues so I think that's
probably a good thing to work on right
now okay so let's bring over let me
bring over the documentation for
material UI as well so we can all check
it out together there we are and that's
just me material UI calm I'll paste it
in so you can go exactly to where I'm at
okay so
there's this swipeable drawer so we're
gonna check out the code first and see
if there are any major changes on
clothes on
all right that's interesting we have
this on clothes and on open I don't
believe we needed that with the regular
drawer but let's double check
okay yeah definitely different
okay it looks like there are some issues
with low-end phones so we'll just we'll
have to be careful that we'll have to
just test that but otherwise you know I
think we can we can use it and we'll
make sure that we we add these in here
that are gonna test let me zoom in a bit
we'll add some of these in to make sure
that we test for whether or not we're on
iOS or not okay so first things first
let's get the import in here so we're
gonna import swipeable drawer
yeah let me move some things around here
so that we can have more more room there
we go
so we're gonna replace your drawer with
swipeable drawer
whoops there we go and then we'll go
down here where we have drawer and
replace that we'll swipeable drawer and
let's make sure down the bottom we also
replace this there we go all right so
I'm gonna save that and see if that even
works at all unexpected token expected
where is that
that's weird how did that happen why did
we get
oh now I remember we we installed a
package that alphabetizes our imports or
something it organizes them somehow
somehow messed things up alright let's
go back here and you see what's going on
now with our code we're gonna refresh to
get rid of anything I had done over here
okay so that's it's still opening which
was expected because of the little
override that I did well we see that
overflow:hidden is not I mean make that
bigger
so the overflow:hidden is still there so
whatever's causing that is still still
in play okay I guess we could try see
what we have currently so
you know we could do since we have that
on open on clothes we could try to do
the switch in the CSS with those it's
like I don't really want to do it like
that but I just I'm just not sure where
the the problem is so let's see what's
going on in these so on open climate on
clothes it is calling toggle drawer and
let's see what's toggle drawer is
knowing all right well so toggle drawer
is really it's it's just changing the
state yeah so nothing in there it is
doing anything with those classes
I all we can do at least is within our
style objects let's see how are we gonna
do this alright let's just make this a I
can't remember I've done this in line
before so let's try it like this let's
make this a template literal so we're
gonna do it like this so template
literal syntax allows us to just put in
JavaScript right in the middle of
strings we can also do things like have
line breaks and things so it's pretty
useful but for this case what I want to
do is say open and I guess
oops oh now I don't want to actually
want it like that I wanted to say we're
gonna do a ternary in here so if it's
open we want it to be visible if not we
want it to be hidden so we want that
value to change and you know what I
don't know I don't think I'll need that
yeah it is gonna make me do that huh
okay let's try it with the template
literal there may be a better way to do
that but if this works I'm gonna go with
that so since everything's run slow I'm
just gonna let that go for a second and
I'll explain this so this is a backtick
character so it's right below the Escape
key and when you do that back to
character everything inside is treated
as a string unless you do a dollar sign
and a curly bracket and then anything in
here until the end of the curly bracket
you treat just like normal JavaScript so
in this case we're using a ternary which
is kind of like a shorthand for an if
statement so we're basically saying if
open is true then we want the value
that's returned out of here to be
visible if it's not true so this is the
else we wanted to say hidden so this
should give us our visibility hidden or
visible just like the behavior that it's
supposed to happen
which I can't figure out why it's not
happening so we're just kind of adding
it in ourselves it's it's a little over
I'd rather not have to do it like this
but if we can't find the real cause of
the problem this this should work for us
so let's check the page
[Music]
all right it popped out and we can see
where's our element area so we have
visibility:visible which is overriding
that visibility:hidden let me make it
bigger you probably can't see there we
go so this is our element that's that's
popped out now visibility:visible it's
overriding the hidden that's in there
now when we click out of here it should
get rid of it yep and it does in reality
what happens is the entire element goes
off the page so we don't really need
that but for some reason in material UI
it seems like that's the way they want
it to work so that's what we're gonna go
with right now okay
next problem in the body we're getting
this overflow:hidden definitely don't
want that
I mean I'm I don't want that let's let's
try this out let's see what happens so
we're getting overflow:hidden right now
let's get rid of it let's see okay
that's why so we don't want this scroll
to happen so to be honest like it's a
bit annoying to have that scroll happen
but to be honest with you if we can't
get rid of it and all we do is override
this overflow:hidden I'm okay with this
scroll happening
I think it's unexpected but it's not
it's not a bug right it's you know I
can't can you think of any drawback to
this actually happening other than just
that's not it's unexpected
because otherwise I mean it would stay
still so let's try this again you know
otherwise I'm trying to scroll right now
with my cursor on this side nothing
happens
this still works I think I might be I
might be okay we're just overriding this
one now the trick is gonna be where do I
override this and what do I set it as
overflow should I just set it to let's
see what I need to set it to for this to
work properly so it should flow initial
initial seems to work let's go with
overflow initial and I'm probably gonna
have to do it in in our global Styles
yeah let's let's check our layout
component because if there is any
component that would give me access to
everything it would definitely be the
layout component so I don't let me get
rid of a few of these we could check no
that's not gonna do anything let's get
rid of that for now and get rid of a few
things that probably not gonna work with
today
all right we don't we're not worried
about the index just yet we may come
back to there though free up some time
and let's go here then and we'll go to
all right my timer just is up so as soon
as I make this change I'm gonna come
back into the live chat and answer some
questions
body there we go so we can't actually
put it right here in the body for a
document je s underscore document touch
is so stir that in there and so we're
gonna end up saying style equals we're
gonna say I'm gonna copy that in but we
definitely will need to put something
around there and then we need our double
brackets waiter sir Oh
spacing and then let's try that out we
may have to put important on there as
well I don't like to use important if it
if it's not absolutely necessary but it
may be absolutely necessary I'm gonna
give it a manual refresh to clear out
what we've done in dev tools
at least we're getting a circular kind
of shadow or whatever that is behind
there all right so we're gonna open that
up we're gonna check out the body still
has overflow initial which is great and
it's actually not scrolling I don't know
it did it changed overflow:hidden all
right so it did still change to
overflow:hidden
yeah
okay I don't think putting important on
there is gonna change anything so what
we'll need to do then is add the
important to the CSS the reason being
the JavaScript is just totally removing
what we had in there before so it will
remove the important
see
all right I need to find a spot where
actually you know what this is gonna be
a little bit weird to do it like this
but let's try this out
I have never attempted to do this but we
already have this in the head here so
let's say style and let's put in body
whoops
still thinking JavaScript and then we're
gonna put that overflow initial in there
they're not gonna let us do this
I don't think it's gonna let us do this
I'm just gonna try it the but I don't
think it's gonna work since we're still
in JSX land here yeah all right how can
we make this happen
the problem is I don't have a I don't
have a style sheet that works everywhere
that's like on every component but you
know what I bet we can have one all
right so let's check out on this side
we're just gonna open up another page so
let's check out the index page and let's
see right now we're pulling in
are we not pulling any of these styles
we're pulling in anything on layout
you know we really aren't okay
there we go there's our global styles a
new ad global style somewhere alright I
can get rid of this then it's good to
know that I can't do that I mean it if
I'd have thought about it for a second I
guess that would have made sense but
sometimes it's faster just to just to
try something the feedback loop is just
so quick when you're developing locally
like this that it almost it's it doesn't
make sense to like overthink something
just you know try it see what happens
and then move on ok so here we can put
overflow initial
and we're also gonna see if it'll let us
add important I'm not sure but I hope it
will if it does this might solve a
problem alright didn't get an error
Suda looks like ok so we're on body
right now see what we've got
yep alright it does say overflow initial
important its openness great alright
check that out so it goes to
overflow:hidden is added to the element
but we're overriding it with that
important tag so that definitely has its
uses its legitimate uses so this will
not work we can close it that
overflow:hidden is gonna remain but it
doesn't really matter right because
we're overriding that so this works I
would still love to know why I had to do
this workaround and why it's not working
as I want to but this is kind of cool we
have this in here now and it's it's
swipeable still need to test that out on
a phone but I'm not gonna do that on the
stream because y'all can't see my phone
anyway so that wouldn't be very fun for
anybody watching ok cool so I definitely
went over my my time on my promo to our
timer I'm gonna scroll up to the top and
just go down through the live chat and
answer any questions that you all have
if you have any question put it in the
chat there now
sigh so si I says hi can you help me
with a problem I'm facing well I will
try since I'm trying to add asynchronous
data and Java scripts I'm trying to find
the sum of asynchronous data but I get
some is 0 hmm I'm not sure sorry if you
had a link to some code you were working
on it would be a lot easier for me to I
I'm not saying that I definitely can
figure it out but it would be a lot
easier for me to figure out that
particular problem
De Anza Borrego channeling your
Destiny's Child sobre hard had said
earlier say my name that's the it's the
name of a Destiny's Child song from the
90's say my name so I definitely get it
I'm pretty sure I could sing most of the
songs off of that CD I'm not gonna to
subject you all to that my singing
though so don't worry
okay John Hanson says is the best honest
livestreams around thank you
I can do that I may not be able to make
anything you know that's out of my hands
I'll try my best but what I can do is at
least be honest when I mess up
shree says did you change the font color
from visual studio code extension I
don't think so Siberian says Jessie
under stress now because of you under
stress because I what did I do to stress
you out
Matthew says hey Matthew how's it going
thanks for watching
Albert says this is one of the longest
projects I've ever seen yeah yeah for
sure I'm so ready for this to be
launched it's going on much longer than
I anticipated Brea
said I cloned the project anyone know
how to launch it no good info in the
readme actually I thought the readme for
this project had instructions let me
double check because if it doesn't it
definitely should so let's go to github
by Microsoft and check out the readme
for this
alright so the readme is just really
basic the contributing has some more
stuff going on but yeah actually it's
not you just get the repo yarn install
or NPM install we are using yarn on the
project so if you have your own use yarn
and then run the dev server with just
dev so NPM to have your yarn dev so it's
really it's assuming that you have node
and NPM installed on your machine
already and get then you know you should
should be able to who sorry should be
able to just follow the instructions
I mean potentially if you had an older
version of node it might not work but
I'm not I'm not sure about it
very hard says Jessie you the man Thank
You turtle says he has no sleep I think
maybe you're talking about me yawning
all the time
I did sleep last night I'm not sure why
I'm so tired
let's see miss miss Arg asks if anyone
knows about CSS grids should I learn CSS
flexbox or CSS grid or both I would say
it's it's good to learn both because
you'll probably run into both and you
can use them together so I don't really
know which one to learn first but I plan
on learning both Chris says learn grid
first
well it says Chris also says CSS grid
kind of has a steep learning curve
Dimitri says hey Jessie how you doing
not too bad not too bad thanks for
asking I actually had a good morning so
some of you may have may remember me
mentioning on the stream or if you
follow me on Instagram that I've been
trying to lose weight so I've been
exercising and dieting so I officially
hit my goal weight this morning at 175
pounds so I lost 15 pounds in the last I
don't know a month or so so I'm pretty
excited about that so that's been cool
so how's everything going for you
Dimitri hopefully well ein bisschen says
is it necessary to use SSH keys for
small digitalocean projects when you run
something on digitalocean if you already
have your key setup you just click a
checkbox and it'll set up the keys for
you like when you're setting up the
droplet so it's it's really not hard
it's not hard to do so I would always
use SSH I don't think you have to you
could use like login with a password but
assuming you've already set them up once
and all it takes is just a click of a
checkbox then I'm not sure why you
wouldn't want to Joey says couldn't you
test the swipeable drawer with dev tools
device toolbar hmm I didn't even think
about that but let's check it out
oh nice it works
haha let's see if it works for us let's
click this first mmm looks like it might
not be working oh but you know what I
did forget to put in some of that code
let me go back here since I I totally
forgot
sister
I was just checking out the other types
of drawers quickly to see if they added
any new types swipeable drawer let's add
this stuff and
and actually we don't have didn't make
this constant yet let's do that
jeff says isn't a swipeable temporary or
did I mess it up
now I think it's the name of it in the
component is just swipeable all right
let's check it out see
okay all right it seems like it works
like once I open it once then it works
maybe it's just you know trying to do it
on here that's kind of messing it up so
I'll have to try it on my phone later
and see if it's different but at least
it's kind of working so it's doing
something different anyway Joe it was a
good idea using the dev tools - Tessa
Zhi Shan says any resources on how to
create nodejs and react I don't know how
to combine them we I mean you almost
always run react with node trying to get
resources I mean usually for most of our
projects we end up doing a custom server
and node so you could check some of
those check out our server das files for
some ideas and and maybe some of the
live streams otherwise you know things
like now the documentation for next Jas
I believe has a section on doing your
own custom server and that's you know
any JavaScript stuff on the server side
is if it's not all node then it's almost
all node so off the top of my head I I
don't really know a tutorial that would
you know specifically look at that part
of it
okay Nikki was asking what's what's 175
pounds in kilograms and says around 79
kilograms so it's John says seventy nine
point three seven nine kilograms thank
you for that
I always forget about the difference in
you know in measurement system so
apologies for that but I now weigh
evidently I weigh seventy nine point
three seven nine kilograms
I'm Bishan says do you have any video on
creating SSH I do not have a video on
that but that's a great idea for a video
so I will put that on my list
phoenix says y no space between buttons
you know what that was one of the things
that that got changed when I upgraded so
that's there's gonna be space between
these I just don't have them right now
so let me let me check just quickly to
see how many pixels of space there
should be okay so it is these dips these
grid deuce and it's gonna end up being
high one of my kids is coming in hi crew
Delia good man you won't be on YouTube
here put your head down she's trying to
like climb back through all kind of
stuff to get to me
hey all right I'll be on YouTube you say
hi say hi
actually I'll work on this later
basically what I need to do is just
there's a spacing prop on the grid items
and I just need to put in a value for
spacing so I'm gonna switch over to my
other screen and see if could you you'll
realize that she's on that look are you
on YouTube who is that ah yeah you say
hello hey hi can you say YouTube no who
is that is that dad on the screen yeah
yeah yeah you won't listen
do you help data on a computer yeah all
right
oh you pressing the buttons okay look
there's lots of people that are talking
to us on there see them type in all
these words there we go
my computer just froze for a second
hopefully this dream was okay help dad
down here let's put this over here I
don't need help with this right now
I need help looking at the screen see
team yeah can we wave to the people
yeah can you say free Oh code we say
code camp ha yay free code camp mom is
mom upstairs yeah yeah I'll come
upstairs in a little bit
Aniki says does that navigator phone
cause problems on the server since
that's not a browser to navigator might
be undefined yeah I want to go upstairs
okay see you later
hi thanks for helping go ahead upstairs
you see mama oh you can give me my water
thank you you're so helpful
yeah I'm gonna stay down here alright
thank you okay so I thought about that
at first but let's let's check this out
I think it's it's already saying like
basically if this is in the browser then
let's check this if not don't worry
about it so I don't think we'll have a
problem with it alright John Hanson says
Nicki's blog has great info on SSH keys
for get home okay cool
yeah Nicki's blog is super helpful Abdul
says hi Heidi the kid John said cutie oh
yeah thanks thanks yeah that's my baby
yeah she wants me to be with me all the
time and have me hold her so she
frequently tries to sneak down here
during the day when I'm working so if
anybody leaves like the door open to the
basement she just she sneaks down and
climbs through the basements like
partially unfinished so there's a little
spot in the wall
where there's actually like a hole that
she can get through and so all the doors
are shut to me but there's still a hole
there
so she sneaks through the hole climbs
under my desk and threw all my cords and
comes here to sit with me so I need to I
need to fix that hole so she can't get
in but uh
okay so I've gotten through all the
questions and we're already at about an
hour for the stream so I think I'm just
gonna I'm not gonna do another Pomodoro
session basically you know but I've
either explained or we work through the
major issues when updating now of course
this depends on what wood pieces you've
used right any parts of material you I
that I haven't used that you know if you
have used that there might be other
issues that I have no idea about so this
is definitely not a comprehensive you
know tutorial on upgrading but hopefully
this will just kind of make you aware of
some of the issues and some of the ways
to get around them and you know we even
did a little bit some overriding of
things here to make it work but I should
be I'm gonna check out a few other
things before I commit this but I should
be committing these changes you know
before I finished for the day so pretty
soon I'm probably gonna be finished in
about a half hour or so so if you if you
want to look at the code it will be
available in about a 1/2 hour
at the latest alright so I think I'll be
back in the office tomorrow so I am a
bit busy with meetings but I think I
should be able to get a stream in so all
I'll announce that stream on Instagram
and Twitter you also get a notification
if you've signed up if you subscribe to
this channel and enabled notifications
so hopefully I'll see y'all tomorrow and
until then have a great day